soldiers scientists adventurers oddities
over 20 million players have started
their watch now we want to showcase the
world's greatest overwatch players
Blizzard Entertainment is proud to
announce the overwatch league a global
world class eSport league designed from
the ground up to celebrate the best of
the best on their path to victory our
seasoned experienced in eSports and the
best practices of time-honored
traditional sports helped to define the
unique structure of the overwatch league
our goal is to create the world's
premier eSport league where teams and
players can thrive for years to come and
fans are made for life let's break it
down each team in the overwatch league
will represent a major city our plan is
to expand the league over time to
include additional teams from the
Americas Europe China Korea and the
asia-pacific region a global league of
the future ensures that fans in every
corner of the world will have a
professional team to root for and will
be able to witness overwatch played at
the highest level the owners of each
team will take an active role in
developing their players internal
structures and team roles League players
can become the most decorated overwatch
professional competitors in the world
when team owners and players share in
league economics stability is a key
factor in making this happen
so once prospective team owners have bid
for their location and successfully
joined teams will have a guaranteed
place in the league while team stability
is paramount player stability is equally
important so each player will have a
contract including compensation and
benefits
early next year before season play
commences the overwatch league will
conduct a combine invited players will
have the opportunity to distinguish
themselves as top talent their stories
amplified by editorial content
documenting the rise of tomorrow's
superstars the combine will help ensure
that all teams have awareness around the
best players following the combine there
will be a signing period where rosters
will be finalized with the team rosters
established the regular season will
commence with land play in front of live
audiences at the end of the regular
season the top teams will compete face
to face in front of the fans in a live
playoffs for exclusive content and
insider access to teams and players a
comprehensive feature-rich website will
serve as the dedicated online hub for
fans providing access to videos player
profiles the latest stats schedules and
more
our mission is to ensure that the
competitors of tomorrow understand the
steps they need to take to become a pro
high ranking placement and competitive
play honing your skills and online
leagues and making a name for yourself
in third party events are all great ways
for aspiring pros to increase the odds
of receiving an invitation to play in
the league our hope is to establish the
overwatch league as a professional
career path open to any and all of the
world's most competitive players
the world needs legendary heroes and
fans to cheer them on in the overwatch
league are you with us